- [Voiceover] In this video
we're gonna talk even some more
about parallel resistors.
Parallel resistors are resistors
that are connected end to end,
and share the same nodes.
Here's R one and R two,
they share the same nodes.
That one and that one.
And that means they
share the same voltage.
And we worked out an expression
for how to replace that
with a single resistor.
R parallel, and we found
that one over R parallel
is one over R one
plus one over R two.
So in this video I'm gonna actually
start working with this
expression a little bit more.
And we'll just change it around
a little bit to an easier,
an easy way to remember it,
and then we're gonna do a special case,
where R one and R two are the same value
and we're gonna see what happens.
So right now I wanna do
just a little bit of algebra
on that expression, one over R p
is the same as
one over R one
plus one over R two.
What I wanna end up with
here is an expression
that on this side says
R p equals something,
and on this side I just
want one expression,
not two fractions.
So we're gonna go about that
by combining these two fractions first.
So the least common denominator here, LCD,
equals R one times R two,
and I'm gonna convert both these
to convert this to that proper denominator
I have to multiply it by R two over R two,
so we'll do it.
We'll do all the steps.
We'll multiply it by R two over R two.
This expression we have to
multiply it by R one over R one.
And this equals, of course, one over R p.
Continuing on, one over R p
equals R two
over R one R two
plus
R one over
R one R two,
and now I can combine them together.
Let's move up here.
One over R p
equals, we'll keep everything
in numerical order,
R one
plus R two over
R one R two.
And now I'm gonna take the reciprocal
of both sides of the expression
so I get an expression in R p,
R p equals, and just flip
over this expression,
R one R two
over
R one plus R two.
That
is a way you can remember how
to combine parallel resistors.
The parallel equivalent resistor, R p,
is the product of the two
resistors over the sum.
So it's the product
over the sum.
That's how I remember it.
Now this arithmetic, this expression,
is exactly the same as the
original one that we had,
these are the same,
and it's just a question of
which one do you want to remember,
which one's easier to remember
and which one's easiest to calculate.
I like to remember this one here.
Let's do a quick example using it.
I'll move the screen up a little bit.
Let's leave that there so we can see it.
Let's say we have two parallel resistors.
And we'll say the first one is 1,000 ohms,
and the second one is 4,000 ohms.
And the question is, what
is the parallel combination
of those things.
How can I replace these with one resistor
so the same current flows.
And we'll use this expression here.
So R p
equals a product which is 1,000
times 4,000
divided by the sum
1,000
plus 4,000
and that equals, oh my goodness
there's a lot of zeroes here.
Four and six zeroes,
one, two, three, four, five, six
over, that's easy, 5,000.
All right?
And let's say,
let's take out three
zeroes out of this one.
Let's knock off three zeroes here,
and three zeroes here.
And I have 4,000
divided by five
and that equals 800 ohms.
So that is this
and that's how we use this expression.
Now just something to notice here,
notice that R parallel, the
equivalent parallel resistor,
is smaller than both of these.
And that happens every time,
that happens every time.
The parallel resistance
is smaller than the smallest resistor.
So here it was 1,000, it's
gonna be smaller than that.
And that's a property
of parallel resistors.
Because you have two current paths
that allow current to
go two different ways,
the effective resistance is always smaller
than the smallest original path,
because there's a way for
current to go around another way.
So this is now the expression
for two parallel resistors,
and that's a good one to remember.
Now I'm gonna show you one special case,
and we'll do this in this color.
What if R one equals R two?
What is R p?
And for this special case,
we use the same expression,
we say R p,
we say R p is the product,
we'll just use R because R is,
it's the same value.
R times R
over R plus R,
and that's multiplied.
And so that is R squared
over two R,
and one of these Rs cancels,
so let's cancel
that R and that squared,
and we end up with
R over two.
So for the special case,
if R one equals R two,
then R p
equals R over two.
It's just half, and
that should make sense.
If we do something like this,
if we draw two resistors in parallel,
like this.
and we say this is 300 ohms
and this is 300 ohms,
that means the effective,
the effective parallel resistor,
150 ohms.
And that's got a very
pleasing symmetry to it
because these resistors are the same,
they have the same voltage,
they're going to have the same current,
basically twice as much current
is gonna flow in this
circuit as would flow
if there was just one of these guys,
so that's where the
divide by two comes from.
So for two resistors in parallel,
if the resistors are the same value,
the effective parallel
resistance is just half.